and joining me now is Arizona
congressman Andy Biggs a member of the
House Judiciary Committee hi congressman
how are you great how you doing Lisa I'm
doing well and Congress said you also
recently sat down with the president on
Saturday to talk about this very issue
so what is it going to take to break
this stalemate well what's going to take
is Chuck Schumer is going to have to
bite the bullet and they're gonna have
to fund the wall they need to pay five
billion dollars which is a substantial
reduction from the twenty five billion
dollars that we will take to actually
build the wall they need to move this is
it's all in chuck schumer's court right
now there's nothing on the President's
desk to veto or sign it this is a Chuck
Schumer's shutdown right now what
incentive do you think Democrats have to
come to the table or to negotiator to
give President Trump any funding you
know Nancy Pelosi is gonna take over
likely as Speaker of the House just next
week and Democrats are gonna have
control of the house so you know what
incentive do they have to play ball here
what's what's going to incentivize them
are two things is if they really love
this country and recognize that the
border is insecure right now and we have
to have a wall that's one thing the
other thing that I think will do it is
if they realize that that they're their
base are significant a number of
bureaucrats and they're the ones who
aren't getting paid in the shutdown and
they're going to get some pressure from
their their base to come to the table
and the reality is they're the ones that
have chosen to shut this down actually
not the president well and you know
congressman isn't this really a lot of
this about politics is the way I see it
you looked at a lot of Democrats
including Senator Chuck Schumer they
voted for fencing along the southern
border clearly they're not again some
sort of physical structure being along
the southern border so isn't the wall
just a semantics game and a politics
game isn't that isn't this just about
denying president Trump that key
campaign promise that he made yeah you
know I actually believe or not I have
friends in Congress who are Democrats
and we talked and I asked them I said
what's the deal here I know I you know
one lives by border wall so what's going
on I said won't you give us anything for
border wall I live in a border state
where we're concerned and they said well
you know what once that I don't like the
rhetoric that President Trump uses and
the other one said we're not going to
give President Trump a victory and so
what I'm telling you is it is politics
Lisa that's the problem is they don't
want president
to have a victory and in so doing
they're preventing this country from
having the safety when I hear people
just today even some more people from
the borders telling you Andy they're
crossing our property we've got to have
we've got to have border wall and you
know what that's what we need to do not
politics
we need good policy which includes a
border wall well in speaking of the
policy aspect even beyond the wall the
big crisis we're facing right now on the
southern border is asylum seekers and
we've seen a massive influx and people
seeking asylum from Central America q
tell the viewers a little bit about
what's going on with asylum seekers and
why we are seeing this influx of Central
Americans doing just that well what's
happening is when an asylum seeker comes
across the border we do an immediate
little evaluation and then they end up
staying we can't keep them longer than
20 days and so we can't process them
because the influx is so great I mean
there's thousands upon thousands and so
for instance in the Phoenix metro area
there's been almost 4,000 of them
released since October until about two
weeks ago that's the total from two
weeks ago that are coming here seeking
asylum they're released into the
interior we pay for them to go wherever
they want to go because we can't afford
to hold them and that's what's happening
is catch and release and we're giving
them a notice please come back we say
for your court hearing to prove that you
really are someone who qualifies and you
know what almost 90 percent of them
don't even qualify for asylum yet
they're already here in this country
most of them never go back for their
hearing that's what's going on with the
asylum policy that we have today well in
something that's not really been
reported as much as this deal with
Mexico and keeping asylum seekers in
Mexico while they're waiting for their
immigration cases because you as you
pointed out you know ninety percent
don't actually get granted asylum an
immigration court and the problem is a
lot of them go missing in between that
time and when their cases come up so why
is this so important well if you can
keep them in Mexico which by the way is
offered a sound like for instance to the
caravan most of the asylum seekers that
they've offered them Asylum if you keep
them there then it gives us time to
process them before they get released
into the interior because once they're
released in the interior they're
effectively lost until they commit a
crime or something like that where we
actually track them down a nice can get
hold of them except for wood unless
there's a sanctuary city that's not
going to cooperate with ice so we have
all kinds of obstacles that keep us from
actually controlling the the folks that
are coming into our country that's why
the Mexico basically hot keeping them
there until they're ready to come in or
qualify to come in is so important
because it's going to reduce the number
of people who come into this country
illegally that we can't track we can't
vet we don't know who they are is
Congress doing anything to address the
asylum issues we're saying we have
basically put together a series of bills
I know the freedom caucus has put
together some ideas and some bills to
try to get this going but the first
thing that has to happen really is the
border wall and when I talked to my
Border Patrol agents here they say Andy
we need the Border Patrol eyes we need
the border wall first because once we
get once we have the border wall it's
going to actually put people into a
channel so they're coming to the ports
of entry we can control that better and
then we can start dealing with interior
interior problems like asylum well real
quick how long do you think this
shutdown is gonna last
well since the president's holding firm
and the Democrats have said they're not
willing to budge on this I I would think
we're going to go at least another
couple of weeks actually actually all
right well congressman I really
appreciate you joining us and giving us
some insight on this issue thank you
thanks Lisa